tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo su chi
enders che un invio ragazzi che
sinceramente ci avevo lì da un bel pezzo
nel senso lo avevo salvato solo che l'ho
ritrovato adesso vi ho detto porca [ __ ]
devo farlo assolutamente è quindi
ragazzi direi di iniziare la c'abbiamo
internet per the forest perfetto vd ddis
tumi chi mi ha fatto questo e poi scappa
via ragazzi sono imbarazzo della scelta
non so chi diavolo sia nostre cose ma
deve rientrare nella foresta perché devo
andare a raccogliere le castagne dove
siamo ragazzi giorni cos'è siamo partiti
in una o commerce ragazzi questo è un
indie horror coi contro maroni perché
come ogni oro che si rispetti si inizia
senza sapere come diavolo ci siamo
finiti qui ragazzi probabilmente eravamo
in autostrada ci si è fermata la
macchina allora ci siamo addentrati in
un bosco abbiamo detto perché non
andiamo a cercare castagne e non cadiamo
nei burroni perché non lo facciamo
e allora l'abbiamo fatto ragazzi sono
caduti in un burrone di 450 metri e sono
ancora vivo a non si sa
guardate sempre dove mettete i piedi se
per caso vi ritrovate nelle foreste
sperdute perché ho pestato una merda
se invece viva ma le cadette in un
burrone di 300 metri e vi assicuro che
non è piacevole vi sconsiglio di
provarlo ragazzi perché poi non so non
so se potete raccontarla come esperienza
ma non importa ragazzi abbiamo raggiunto
la casetta della norma siamo tipo in
cappuccetto rosso forse io io
non me ne frega un cazzo
apri l'acquisto perfetto non so chi
erano quelli di fuori ma ho visto
qualcuno vi giuro che ho visto qualcuno
bene così ragazzi se c'era qualcuno
nella foresta non mi interessa si sbatte
altamente le balle via di qua te c'è
mica un telefono no perché tre minuti di
video sono caduto da un burrone
ho il contratto dei tizi cos'è penso che
abbia bisogno di la chiave per aprire la
porta perfetto è è un è la stanza da
letto bene così alla ragazza c'era dei
pizzi fuori non so chi fossero non mi
interessa ma era gente veramente brutta
ancora non ho capito bene che cosa devo
fare ma andiamo avanti prima che quei
tizi mi facciano il culo gas però non
entrino in casa non è tutto blindato
credo se siamo in cucina dove la nutella
ho bisogno della mia nutella ragazzi ho
bisogno di tranquillizzarmi con qualcosa
perché l'ho vista
[Musica]
buongiorno si scusa io non volevo di
disturbarti assolutamente stavo cercando
la nutella non c'è nel frigo assenti per
caso ce l'hai toto al gorelli disturbo
grazie 1600 molto simpatico via di quei
ragazzi chi cazzo è quel tizio bene si è
chiusa la porta bene così io non torno
in cui centro perfetto quello faceva più
paura di benedetta parodi e gordon
ramsay messi insieme non voglio vederlo
cucinare maledizione dove siamo
altro è buonissimo non vedo quasi una
mazza ma non importano innovati e denti
e non voglio disturbare ragazzi e questo
big block che perfetto allora cucino io
cugino tutti cazzo siete sentite
mettetevi d'accordo cioè non ho capito
se dovete spaventarmi almeno fatelo
insieme in poche parole non so ragazzi
io non ho capito bei quadri che fi
questo è il quadro più bello che io
abbia mai visto in tutta la mia vita
shadows of courage è che sta operando vi
odio è fantastico sto quadro è
fantastico comunque io non ci tengo a
tornare davvero prima ti ringrazio james
pelati non ci dovrebbe essere una chiave
da chi da qualche parte per i topi e sta
a porta ha capito che mi serve la chiave
maioli dietro non ci torno forse non hai
capito
[Musica]
raga mi sa che mi conviene portarmi di
porno allora senti zio allora la vedi
questa questa è una sedia la vedi questa
no cazzona segno mi serve la sede di
serve a prima ma volte a [ __ ] bene
questa era una sedia senza amico tim
braico il tesoro tutti i barattoli di
nutella che vuoi mamma ma scaccia il tuo
amico di là che non riescono andarci
maledizione aspettate un attimo dov'è
andato dov'è
da qui ragazzi io vi giuro di aver visto
qualcuno non c'è più
non c'è più chi mi ha preso mi ha preso
per il cap ranzi loro dottori caso è si
è nascosto nell'armadio cosa cioè io per
una donna che chiave che dovete la
infili questo amico mio dove ragazzino
perché io io non voglia di tornare
indietro cazzo
torniamo ma soltanto perché ho la chiave
sono non ci tornerei più quale ho
dimenticato o dimenticato qualcosa non
perfetto allora vediamo di uscire prima
che qualcuno ci stupri da dietro senti
zio io ho trovato la chiave e io valva
doni l'area è un piacere conoscerti
dunque sei bellissimo vado di quattro
titola la sedia te la regalo sentite e
io non uso dall cosa sto andando a
trovare lì sotto non ci vorrei andare ma
ci devo andare purtroppo raika pregate
per me
buongiorno senti gli occhi ho incontrato
nella stanza di prima barca tra gli
achei ok
vai così non c'è più testa adesso è
sparito ragazzi sta gente sparisce non
si sa perché sparisce ragazzi non capita
sinceramente se sta gente c'è il
mantello dell'invisibilità di harry
potter che così sparisce o cose del
genere ma sinceramente ancora il senso
cos'è cos'è cos'è che ha scoraggiato
cos'era ragazzi come come si esce di qua
fate cosa esca porta promette benissimo
non mi devo fare entrare qui dentro
proprio un giorno senti zio allora fermo
per cazzo non funziona già allora
funziona per no vabbè dove imparare la
sa cosa mi oddio mi serve nelle
interrogazioni va beh raga non ho capito
bene che cosa che cosa sta succedendo lì
preciso ma non importa lampadine mio dio
civiltà civiltà hanno inventato
l'elettricità fantastico sta cosa
sa cosa mi mi rende veramente felice non
ci posso credere ragazzi cosa dovrei
fare in sto gioco non ho ancora capito
boh io torno indietro perché la reggina
fa accendere tipo tutte le candele o
cose del genere non lo so
infatti c'è anche questa raga io non ho
capito il senso di sta roba mamma stesso
tizio allora premi zio tu sei l'unico
che non è scomparso non ho capito bene
se devi io mi avvicino piano piano piano
allora fermo fermo ma è bellissimo mi
sono innamorato troppo
[Musica]
sentiti o fammi capire una cosa tu sei
l'unico che non è scomparso
perché non hai il pene vabbè io io mi
avvicino allora tu stai calmo stretta di
mano quella [ __ ] [ __ ] arriva in
testa maledizione ce l'ha fatto cazzo
dopo mezz'ora
mio zio se anche ha bruciato alla
lampadina ma chi se ne fotte cielo fatto
ragazzi allora nella casa della nonna è
finalmente tornata la luce e non ho la
più pallida idea di che cosa mi serva
però almeno vedo di più
ciò vuol dire che se è tornata la
corrente posso vedere la televisione
ascoltami ho acceso le luci c'è puoi
uscire non ti mangia nessuno è mai quel
che cazzo vuoi o prova essere gentile
con la gente li aggancia il credito
prima [ __ ] ragazzi acceso le luci
ovunque la non ho capito che cosa devo
fare armadio non si apre e ovunque la
roba non so finally hacking et sons
finalmente posso dormire
cos'è si è messo a dormire e fini è
finito così è andato a dormire ragazzi
buonanotte a tutti
ricordatevi la già prima di andare a
dormire di accendere il generatore
perché sennò vi trovate i folletti per
casa non chiedetemi perché comunque
ragazzi l'importante che si è andato a
dormire e cioè più amico sia rimasto
nell'armadio sinceramente non ci andrà a
dormire con un mostro in armadio ma va
bene così anche ragazzi che ho incluso
più l'episodio come gioco del nonsense
però verrà fatto abbastanza bene
comunque
evviva piaciuto chiave al solito alciato
il commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come ogni video trovata nella
descrizione dei prescritti iscrivetevi e
noi ci rivediamo un profilo vinto bei
ragazzi